hi there Steve Kaufman here I just want
to quickly do a video to tell you that
my youtube channel was hacked today I
don't know why people do that kind of
thing we've recovered control of my
channel and gotten rid of various videos
that were placed there um and you know
as I approached the new year I'm going
to go skiing up at big white which is in
the interior British Columbia so I was
up doing a bit of cross-country skiing
in the local mountains and they didn't
took some video there which i'm going to
show you it's a half hour from where we
are here where i am it's a green and wet
and about four five six degrees
centigrade and up there is more around
zero and they've got five six meters of
snow so i'll show you that shortly um so
far as my plans for the new year i'm
going to continue to maintain my check
in my russian and prove them slightly
hopefully and continue to focus on
korean targeting a visit to Korea either
in May or in October where I will try to
do the same five days to fluency but I
hope spend a little longer there and I
hope that I'll get my Korean up to level
where I understand it well enough and
have enough vocabulary so that a short
stay there will you know really bump my
Korean along and I want to get into that
you understand a little more about Korea
and how Koreans think and what they say
and read stuff that they say and hear
things that they say and they you know
add that little bit even though i'm far
from where i should be in Russia check
uh I'll keep them going listen daily to
my sources there but I'm going to add in
the Korean see how much time I have to
do all those things and now I will take
you up to where I was yesterday up on
Cypress Bowl which is a just about a
half hour from my home thank you and if
I don't speak to you again all the best
for 2013 bye for now I am half an hour
from my home decided to come skiing so
you see me and you'll notice that i have
my earphones i happen to be listening to
russian today I could have done some
Korean or some check but I chose to
listen to
and of the Year discussions that there
come a squeak and now we'll see it okay
oh my god turn this thing around so
you'll see the skiers here and the snow
and here's a lot here and there you see
more people outside the lodge I'll turn
around and here it says still early in
the season so it's a dangerous thin ice
blah blah blah snowshoe trail that's
that right and back to me here we are
I'm walking because I can't be filming
still visiting my Russian mind you but
here is this lovely winter wonderland
you see the large trees pro trees mostly
some cypress trees here very large trees
in the rainforest which of course is in
snow here we got about five meters of
snow up here on the mountain only half
an hour from where we're getting rained
on all the time so I know I want to get
back to my very interesting discussion
on nickel mostly where they're talking
about the fate of Alexei Navalny and the
various leaders of the opposition and
the including increasingly repressive
policy that Putin is taking which is all
very fascinating so I get back to that
and talk you later don't know how well
this is gonna come out but on my way
down from Cypress Bowl decided I would
stop
to shoot picture of Vancouver live down
there below us you can see the ship's
harbor / little bit so we see the
looking at the bottom here you got the
north bank clipper then you can just
perhaps make out the Lions Gate Bridge
with lights on it leads us into their
and but I think probably not too easy
see you can see the mountains